Reinforcement learning is different
enough from the other ideas in machine
learning that Georgia Tech
actually has a separate class on
it as well as covering it in
the original machine learning class.
So those are the two classes we're
mostly going to draw from in this unit.
We're going to draw from
the reinforcement learning section
of the original machine learning
class and then from the stand alone
reinforcement learning class that's
also offered at Georgia Tech.
Try and keep those straight.
So the main things we'll cover in
this are the different methods for
doing reinforcement learning.
We'll cover mark of decision processes,
which are one of the major
knowledge representations for
understanding reinforcement learning.
We'll cover how reinforcement
learning includes some elements of
game theory and
multi agent interactions.
And we'll cover other methods for
actually doing reinforcement learning.
Along the way, we really want
you to focus on three things.
Again, we want you to focus on
how reinforcement learning fills
in the model building phase
of the original workflow.
We want you to focus on how you
evaluate different models produced
by reinforcement learning for
the relative strengths or disadvantages.
We also what you to focus on
how reinforcement learning
differs in the kinds
of models it produces
compared to the other form of machine
learning that we've talked about so far.